e
I'll open the uh public hear sorry
public discussion the sub committee for
House Bill
587 relative to New Hampshire first
designation on the donor registry for
anatomical
gifts um chairman
McDonald uh was kind of enough to reach
out to legal for legal advice and based
upon that advice which was from
James Cante thank you Cante um based
upon his opinion which basically says
this is a potential conflict with and
preempted by federal law and also
potential conflict with urrent New
Hampshire law my recommendation I think
for the committee to discuss is that
legal interpretation because if it
stands the way it's written I think we
need to itl the
bill but I'd love to hear from the other
folks on the
subcommittee chairman I yes they just
following up on that um I talked to
attorney seans who's the house legal
counsel and and he didn't offer an
official opinion but he said that that
there's a reason to believe that it
could conflict with other state laws I
was just looking from my copy I printed
out the email last night and I I don't
seem to have it handy but um it
indicated it could create a conflict
with other state statutes and also
ultimately uh federal law and a there a
uh very problematic to say the least
so
the other thing which I think is also
Brewing or out unsettled at current time
is the federal did federal government
did change the federal statutes which
CMS is working its way through and
trying to understand how to interpret
the federal law uh through regulations
on how
to break AP part they consider to be in
Monopoly if you will I think at that
point in time a lot of the Federal
Regulations are still to be done and
still to be written and I think at this
point in time it's premature for us even
with the interpretation from our legal
council but given what's going on the
federal level for us to move forward in
this
bill
Plaza so I I read the conclusion of
legal council is not conclusive it could
conflict but uh maybe it won't conflict
with a uh uh Federal loss or loss in
other states and uh I still think that
there there was some Merit and what this
bill was trying to solve like we still
have some shortage of organs and uh then
there are some additional questions
about like organ quality uh but
um I intend to join you uh in in your
decision because um I see that uh this
bill is just not ready uh doesn't have
enough support and statistics and uh uh
as far as I saw uh there are some other
ideas some other uh pieces of
legislation uh coming our way thank you
thank you repr yeah thank you um also
I've heard and I I got it second hand
but from a good source that the prime
sponsor of the bill representative
Kimbrell's is is comfortable with itl
also thank you represent mury thank you
um I was not on the subcommittee for
this uh bill that was retained but I was
asked to sub in today um uh
in you know from my perspective from a
clinical
perspective you know regardless of legal
you know interpretation you know to me a
bill of this nature is antithetical to
the care of patients meaning that if you
give preference to a patient for an
organ that they need but because of
geography it is not allowed to happen
that really does speak to the ethical
nature of this and the concerns and I
think it would also be very harmful as I
mentioned previously in the spring it'd
be very harmful the patients in the the
citizens of New
Hampshire right now currently the only
organ transplant that's done in the
state is basically basically kidney
transplants at Dartmouth Hitchcock and
if states in the New England organ donor
you know group that coordinates these
transfers uh these
transplants um uh were to be compromised
in their ability to facilitate those
kind of procedures then our patients our
citizens would be harmed if for instance
somebody needed a heart lung transplant
in Boston but Boston says you know they
don't take ours we're not going to take
yours you know I mean we're really
harming ourselves in many way because we
don't have the resources to do the type
of transplants that many of our Citizens
need in the state um so I understand the
intent was to try to protect our own
individuals but frankly from a clinical
perspective it is really going to be
harmful to our citizens uh as it was
written um it would also be I think
unethical to withhold a transplant to a
patient who is higher on the list
because of need um and also it would
potentially
compromise transplants in general
because time is of a very limiting
factor when you have an organ that could
be transplanted and if you are
restricted by the ability of um an organ
transplant team to say I have to check
with everybody in New Hampshire before I
use this organ then I I I think the
organ itself could die in a cooling bag
you know before it could get to the
right person so you know I again I
wasn't on the subcommittee but I would
just voice my concerns about this
concept in general from a a medical
clinical perspective so thank you thank
you is there any more discussion for the
committee if not I'd like to entertain a
motion by
somebody can I do it as a sub yes i'
like I make a motion to itl um House
Bill 587 and is there a second second
okay we have a motion on the floor to
itl from representative mvy seconded by
representative McDonald all those in
favor say I I I all those opposed
abstain the eyes have it recommendation
to the full committee will be
ideal and we stand
adjourned
e
that's all that's all
yeah
Solutions good morning everyone and
welcome to the house committee on Health
and Human Services and elderly Affairs
uh we have a number of bills to consider
an executive session this morning but
before we do that I'd like you to please
join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible liberty and
justice for
all thank you
everyone Welcome to our two substitutes
today I represent ative cert and
representative Murray yeah
welcome okay um begin at the beginning
as they say the first bill that we
considered this morning is a house bill
322 uh relative to establishing a
committee to study the New Hampshire
Board of Medicine representative
Nagel like to make a motion for our to
pass okay is there a
second
second okay would you like to speak to
you motion representative um yeah the
only thing I'm going to say for me is
that um in subcommittee we voted for to
zero um and I've elected to delegate the
discussion to my much more
learned um partner colleague U
representative Murphy who's the
co-sponsor of the
bill representative Murphy thank you um
yes uh representative Nagel um emailed
me five minutes ago and said would you
mind presenting
this
but having said that he did I know I'm
only kid
um
um um myself and representative Merchant
and uh several others are on the um uh
HHS oversight Committee in last fall it
came to our attention that there was an
incident that occurred uh in a health
you know facility in the state um that
was reported U by an outside um news
source uh and what we came to realize
was that there was a malpractice there
was multiple malpractice suits by a
provider 20 in fact that were reported
on the Board of Medicine website in
Massachusetts and this paper was out of
Boston so they picked up on it and when
they curiously looked at the Board of
Medicine website in New Hampshire not
one of these um lawsuits was U mentioned
so it came to our attention that perhaps
there was um uh a process problem um uh
in reporting and in um uh transparency
with um um for the patients in the state
to understand exactly who is taking care
of them and what may be going on so we
initially looked at this after about
three or four sessions whereby we had
multiple people come in and testify
about uh what had potentially happened
and without trying to specifically
uh get into the weeds or even litigate
potentially uh the incident itself we
became aware that this this is more of a
process issue so our concern was not
with any incidents that happened prior
to that it was more of a a go forward
process issue that we were looking at
specifically with reporting of uh
potential uh malpractice or um um
grievances or complaints that occur in
any Healthcare facility in the state and
how does that information then get to
the Board of Medicine uh to oplc and and
and how they acted upon how they how do
they get the information by whom does
that information from whom does that
information come from within the
healthcare facility um once it gets to a
the Board of Medicine who basically um
interprets the the complaint and how is
a decision made we came to realize that
uh one of the issues in the Board of
Medicine is that most complaints if not
all complaints are vetted by a single
retired physician and oftentimes you can
get with a complaint charts and charts
from a patient's record and it's very
difficult to sip through them and
without any executive summary or any
clear
understanding issues may be Mis
misinterpreted or even missed altogether
so we came to realize that it's
potentially a problem in the Board of
Medicine that they're underst staffed
which I think they probably are but also
the fact that you know there may be a
need for a more robust vetting process
uh House Bill 445 was put forward that
was basically trying to um uh help
support financially oplc it went through
Edna and um pass out Edna ought to pass
but was retained in I believe Ways and
Means subsequent to that so one of the
issues that we then came up with was you
know maybe we need to understand the
process a complaint is made
whether it comes to a malpractice suit
in a healthcare facility how does that
get to the Board of Medicine who then
interprets what happened how is the
decision made as to any consequences
whether it be um basically a reprimand
up to and potentially loss of
license how is that then reported on the
board of medicine and how is that then
ultimately available to the public to
understand exactly who taking care of
them what their track record is and that
sort of thing so we initially thought
that potentially we could put forward
legislation that would give us some
guidance and some regulations and we
realized quite early on in the process
that we really didn't understand the
process well enough and therefore
instead of potentially coming up with
regulations or legislation that would um
either say you got to have more
resources for the Board of Medicine or
um the the reporting facility has to
generate um um you know a more clear uh
executive summary of what happened um
how does the process then get through to
the Board of Medicine and then report it
on the website so that patients know and
to my mind it really becomes a quality
of care issue you have to understand you
know who is taking care of you you have
to understand if there's been any
problems I mean to have 20 lawsuits in a
neighboring state none reported on our
website really is not very transparent
and it doesn't help our patients and
becomes potentially dangerous so we
didn't want to get into the weeds of and
so then you have to understand what then
gets reported on the
website I can tell you that there's a
lot of lawsuits that occur that are
frivolous you know and you know if if a
patient has a complication and they have
a lawsuit they're entitled to have a
lawsuit but it may be a frivolous
lawsuit that never gets to you know a
court or any kind of um um adjudication
but I mean we have books written on
complications in surgery I mean there's
a reason we have those because they are
they exist and every time there's a
complication doesn't mean you get sued
so we didn't want to have every
potential lawsuit you know we could have
put forward legislation that said every
lawsuit is on the website that can be
potentially terribly damning to any
provider uh it takes a lot of time it
takes a lot of emotional toll and it's
just not fair so we were trying to
figure out what we needed to have
reported on the website so the bottom
line is to all of this is that we
understand there's a potential process
problem we understand that the public
needs to be
informed in our society we are coming to
the point where we are losing trust in
some of the more venerable aspects of
our society whether it's politics clergy
health care and this is a way to try to
restore trust in healthc care in the
state whereby we can put forward a very
transparent process to understand
exactly who is taking care of these
patients and they can then choose but
they they have to have available the
information and so what we decided
instead of putting forward any specific
recommendations to the Board of Medicine
or any
legislation was to simply try to come up
with a committee not a commission but a
committee uh with um a few uh Amendment
CLE one amendment that we did that
representative Merchant Drew up that uh
instead of having three we had four
members of the house two from Edna and
two from uh HHS uh and then also two
members from the Senate and I'm sorry
yes could we have the amendment
number uh let me see I think it's two at
the very top here 23422 is that
right is it under
yeah I don't think we have the amendment
I don't think we have the amendment this
was what was drawn up and I'm not sure
that we have the amendment at this point
in time is that an amendment you're we
want to move forward this morning or I
believe so yes um excuse me was it was
it if I may Mist yeah sure go ahead was
it has it been drafted already or is
this something that is in drafted I
think it is in drafting is that correct
okay then we can't vote on it now okay
so if we can't vote on it now it might
be a good idea to either wait till the
end of this session to see if it's
drafted or to take it up on the 13th
because we can't vote on it unless we
have of course the event sure of course
understood yeah I was going to say this
that what we were planning on is
basically to change the makeup of the
committee and also to incorporate into
the invited guests that would be invited
on a regular basis um as stakeholders in
into the process would be the um the
nursing association as well aside from
that there was no significant material
changes uh that we were coming up with
but again I wanted to mention it that
was what the only change that we had to
the original bill when was the amendment
submitted to
alls I represent M did you know don't
know that CHR is that something you
could check on for us or does he have
where it
is
that's okay one sure
sure yeah and and did you did you submit
it or because it looks to me looking at
the people that nobody submitted it I
think I thought you
did so I I think it needs to be
submitted to OS I agree yeah and we need
to take it up on the 13th yes okay
okay y
okay all right well
um all right well in that case
we'll
yes do I have to do this next week
please no hope please no and it wasn't
five minutes
no he he
said all right so we will continue HB
322 to next week um and we're looking at
a 10:00 a.m. start time next week I
don't I believe I don't believe any of
the subcommittees will need to meet
representative Weber do you know of any
subcommittees for next week I know that
not that I'm aware of no I sat on had
had resolutions that
were um unanimous so
all right so we will uh we'll we'll be
convening uh next uh Monday the 13th at
10:00 a.m. and we'll continue HB 322 to
that time at which point we will take up
the amendment as well as the full Bill
all right moving along uh HB 329
establishing an ALS registry in New
Hampshire uh representative Murphy that
was your bill and you and I had talked
and I don't know if you care to make a
motion on that or I would I would make a
motion to it
329 okay is there a second to that
motion representative Nel thank you
representative
not uh would you like to speak to your
motion briefly
um uh this was a bill uh to establish an
ALS registry in the State uh initially
as drafted we were going to have it
housed and supported through the state
um it became obvious that the fiscal
note in the responsibility to do so
would be better um if we could do it uh
at DH through the summer so we retained
it at that point in the spring through
the summer I met with DH legal it uh
medical folks and it became very
apparent to all of us that at this point
in time they um were not going to be
able to um logistically and
operationally set up a registry and
support it financially and also dealing
with the IT issues of confidentiality so
at that point in time we we agreed uh
and Dr stel Who a neurologist uh who uh
asked me to um submit this um is now
trying to think about Alternatives or
working on alternatives to get a
registry started in the state so as of
now uh our request is to itl uh
329 okay any questions on the bill any
other discussion on this
motion seeing none I'll ask the Clark to
coloroll motion is to itl HB 329 FN
representative representative Lon
yes representative kushman yes
representative King yes representative
kofalt
yes sorry my's not no problem
representative uh
represent representative mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative
Nagel representative POF
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus
yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy
yes representative
Sebert
yes and representative Murray yes and
representative McDonald yes 20 to Zer I
would move consent Mr chairman okay
there's no objection we'll put that on
the consent calendar thank you Mr
chairman yes Merchant
um the Amendment for House Bill 322 was
sitting in my inbox so I know you sort
of wanted to wait until next week and we
possibly do it this week by bring the
amendment back to the commit do it this
week all right I'll direct the
researcher is doing the printing of the
amendment to get it to the committee
okay right thank
you
excellent okay reopen that one or if you
want to wait well yeah we don't have the
amendment yet so we'll
continue uh HB 406 FN is next uh
representative kofalt would you like to
speak to that I make a
motion thank you I I move itl on House
Bill
406 is there a second second uh would
you like to speak to your motion sure so
um as the prime sponsor of House Bill
406 um I was concerned with the uh the
need for parents and I am concerned with
the need for parents to have um adequate
access to their children's medical
records um what uh and and Hippa does
Grant parents access to most of their
children's medical records with certain
exceptions um defined in New Hampshire
statute and federal law um the real
sticking point here or the real concern
is that
um portal access which is how most
people typically get information about
their medical records medical
appointments and so forth um is simply
turned off when a child turns 12 and um
what we learned through this process is
that that is primarily driven by a
technical limitation in the software
provided by uh vendors who who um create
software for electronic medical records
and so forth and the portal software
that accesses those records so um it is
a technical limitation at this point um
the federal government has acknowledged
this as well because they excluded
patient portals from the uh the
information blocking rule uh for
technical reasons as well this is still
an issue that I would like to see
resolved however it does not seem
appropriate to try to resolve it with
legislation at this time uh which is why
I'm moving itl thank
you um any other discussion on this
motion okay the motion is itl to itl HB
46 FN I'll ask the clerk to call the
rooll representative Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King
yes representative kofalt yes
representative mlan yes representative
Seth King yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
pelo yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon
yes representative nut upam
yes representative shapira
yes representative
Merchant yes representative Murphy yes
representative Sebert
yes representative Murray yes and
representative McDonald yes 20 to
zero okay no objection I will ask that
that be put on the consent
calendar okay next up uh HB 554 FN uh
representative Nagel do you have a
motion I have a motion for interim study
for this
bill okay is there a second
um would you like to speak to your
motion sure I apologize for sending two
long-winded amendments to you that we
don't really need anymore I hope um so
this bill is very important to me I've
been involved in this bill for about
five years now um it's been presented a
couple times basically the goal of it is
we understand that an opioid Crisis
happen because patients don't have
access to other therapies and it's been
our goal for a long time for me
personally for over 30 years to improve
access to other options for care um
that's kind of where this bill came from
originally it was originally presented
by um representative Maja py I think
four years ago was
preco and um we looked at it as a group
of stakeholders and we looked at the
bill and we we like the concept but we
didn't like the bill and we sat down and
talked with her about it and wanted to
create a an ad hoc Group which we
eventually did to study it come up with
a better bill um subsequently
representative lungren who was the
sponsor of the bill and is involved in
what our current efforts are um took it
on really without changing anything and
we sat down talked with them and said we
really need to fix this bill we think
that it's important but not the way it
is the St was when I gave it to him he
functionally took our bill stuck it in
that bill and now we have two bills in
one one of which actually made it to
Commerce so this bill exist exists in
two different forms and two different
committees which became a real problem
um with that said um and I've talked to
Chairman hunt about this as well and I I
think that this bill is extremely
important um going forward to really
drive the discussion about how do we
improve access to care to a bride
variety of therapies and what's the best
ways to do it the good news is we passed
HB 66 which has created a committee to
look at these issues and we feel um in
our committee that this is extremely
important that we um keep this bill
alive um if necessary work on it the
good news is the interim committee
already exists um representative McKay
representative Merchant myself and
representative lren are already working
on these issues right now and we have a
broad group of stakeholders that are
involved including insurers which I
think is incredibly important um as well
as all the different providers of the
different services that would be
affected by this and I think that that's
important it's unusual to see that kind
of cooperation in healthc care issues
like this so um at this point the bill
is important to me that it stay alive um
that I think that it can be worked on if
we need to and that we can make it um
work to improve access to these
therapies that these people really don't
have right
now okay thank you any discussion
representative
Weber I just wanted to say that I I
think that that's a good resolution for
this bill because um all of us I think
join in the concerns about providing the
widest range of treatment options for
people in chronic pain uh the issue is
that the bill is
drafted um and this has been an issue
that's been hard to Grapple with is the
the number of modalities ities that are
in here some of which are licensed
professions and therefore might lend
themselves well to insurance
reimbursement some of which are things
that uh may have a variety of
practitioners who vary from the very
well-trained very ethical very competent
to the completely unregulated and that
that's a concern I think again for all
of us so um knowing that the people
involved are are in fact very involved
and want to keep this conversation going
forward and there is a study committee
I'm very comfortable with the interim
study recommendation and I thank the
committee for its work and I thank you
representative Nel that was that was
perfect I mean we all agreed with
everything that you just said and it's
been exciting to create Innovative
strategies on how to finance all these
things in in a New Hampshire way because
that's the challenge is to do it our way
not somebody else's way um but that's
what we're doing thank
you other
discussion seeing none I'll ask at the
clerk call a roll motion is to send uh
HV 554 FN to interim
study representative lean yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kof
yes representative mlan yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
peloso yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay
yes representative fra representative
Fus
yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative merch Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Sebert yes representative Murray yes
representative McDonald yes 20 to zero
okay thank you and again if there's no
objection U we'll put that on the
consent
calendar uh an interm study uh motion
needs a committee report as does all of
these so um as as November 17th looms
please try to get your committee reports
into me in the next couple of days
possible um um I'm sorry representative
Merchant I was able to find the
amendment to 322 okay theair for that
whenever the chair would like to sure go
ahead let's go back to it
then
I was just about to ask if it had
arrived yet I I saw her come in with
some papers
so and my apologies to the committee for
losing it in my inbox well thank you for
finding it though thank you
forisa
okay thank
you I'll give you mine that's all
right you were just too anxious for
that well I I remembered the subject
matter I'll say composition of the sub
committee
I do have one plenty extra so I think
they've got
several okay uh going back to HB 322 and
the amendment uh number 2365 H
representative Murphy did you want to
speak to this or who wants to speak to
it I there's three uh three corespond
representative Merchant representative
Nagel and representative Parmer so and
representative parmer's not here so and
we'll need somebody to move the
amendment as well I I would move to pass
Amendment um uh 23
65h okay motion's been made uh is there
a
second I'll second the minut
representative Merchant seconds would
you like to speak to your motion
representative Murphy the um uh rather
than belabor any further points about
House Bill 322 the only changes that
this amendment um made was that it made
uh the committee um uh make up four
members of the house two two of whom
would be from HHS and two would be from
Edna two members from the house from the
Senate and also includes in the um
invited um uh uh members of the um for
for attendance would be a member of the
New Hampshire nurse practitioner
Association uh there was one date change
at the very bottom um from November 20
November 1st of 2023 to November uh 1st
of 2024 so substantively no real changes
uh to the original Bill thank you other
discussion representative Merchant oh
I'm sorry representative uh Leon uh
thank you Mr chairman um I had also seen
this whole process as it showed up over
that previous summer and did it happen
in an area where I had I had worked I
had worked with these implantable
devices um so to me some of that path
was a little bit more transparent than
people working in other areas of
medicine we had submitted another bill
House Bill 4554 which made it through
the house but unfortunately died on the
other side over in the Senate and
therefore I think let's move full steam
ahead with this because we need to make
sure that um people aren't going in
blind to procedures when there's
information about risks especially
regarding the person doing the procedure
that they're otherwise unaware
of okay other
discussion seeing no other discussion
I'll ask the clerk to call the all
motion is ought to pass on Amendment
d2365 on House Bill
322 representative Lon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
Palo yes representative Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative Fus
yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
cber yes representative Murray yes and
representative McDonald
yes 20 to
Z Amendment passes okay Amendment passes
20 to Z do I have a motion to a v to
pass as
amended representative Murphy I would
like to make a motion to ought to pass
with Amendment on House Bill uh 322
thank you is there a second
representative
Nel any
discussion seeing none I'll ask that the
if he's
ready I'll ask the clerk to call it
all representative Lon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
yes representative pza yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative nut upam yes
representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Sebert yes representative Murray yes and
representative McDonald yes 20 to
zero again if there's no objection we'll
put that on the cons sent
calendar okay next up is
566 representative can and you a
chairman of that subcommittee and I
believe the prime sponsor do you wish to
make a motion yes I I move itl uh the
house bill 566 okay is there a
second representative kushman seconds
representative Canon would you like to
speak to your motion yes
um I as we were discussing this to start
off with we recognized that we did not
have enough information we asked our uh
for additional research information to
identify what funding was available and
it was know we were made aware that
funding was already in the house budget
as well as from outs outside resources
and because of that information uh we
voted to itl uh this bill recommendation
of itl uh
unanimously thank you any other
discussion representative
Weber I would just say that this bill
like several others that we've
considered in subcommittees is a prime
example of a bill that was filed at a
time when there was a very great need
and and circumstances have changed I'm
I'm glad that we held on to it but it
appears that the problem has
been nibbled at if not addressed
completely if not devoured been that
precisely any other
discussion okay representative kushman
yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
pelo yes
representative Weber
yes representative McKay yes
representative freedus yes representive
Canon yes representive Nutter upam
yes represent Shapiro
yes represent Merchant yes represent
Murphy yes representative Sebert yes
representative Murray yes represent
McDonald yes 20 to
Zer okay again if there's no objection
we will put that on the consent
calendar uh next up is HB 580 uh
relative to establishing a children's
vision screening initiative within the
State Medicaid Program uh and speaking
with a few members this morning of this
committee we've decided to uh continue
of the consideration of that till next
week uh for our executive session on
November nember 13th at 10:00 a.m. so we
will be taking up HB 580 next week on on
the
13th moving on to HB
587 uh relative to a New Hampshire first
designation on the donor registry for
anatomical
gifts um I'm I'm going to make a motion
to itl that bill uh do I have a second
second okay representative Merchant
seconds um
the subcommittee for that bill I was
comprised of Representative Merchant is
the chairman representative Parmer
representative POF and
myself uh there was a question about um
how that might about the legal aspects
of that uh I did uh confer with house
legal counsel and uh that does have the
potential of conflicting with current
New Hampshire state law specifically RSA
263 col 41 by allowing a New Hampshire
first check box but such an amendment
might conf conflict with the provisions
of RSA 291a The Uniform Anatomical Gift
Act um so that's that's one concern that
this bill raises another bill another
issue is it might conflict or be
preempted by federal
law so uh after uh after being um after
hearing these things from house legal
councel uh he's not offering a
definitive opinion but certainly he's
raised some serious questions it makes
no sense to to um pass a law that's
going to conflict with other statutes
and that and hence my recommendation I
also heard last night that Prime sponsor
of this amend of this legislation is um
amenable to the itl motion from what I
recall uh from last night uh any
discussion at all on this
motion uh representative Lon uh thank
you Mr chair chman um yes the prime
sponsor of this bill uh believes that
this bill and other efforts were part of
the understanding that um that there
were some challenges in the Unos organ
organ Network and um so this whole
process has changed there's some work
being done at the federal level which
may lead to more Equitable um
distribution of organs so he believes
that this bill should be ited but the
fact that we discussed about it was very
very helpful so he thanks everybody for
their
time any other the discussion yes
representative
palazov thank you Mr chair I think this
bill was uh trying uh to address some
real problems that uh we don't have
enough organs uh uh for organ donations
and uh anything we can do to stimulate
it uh we should do while balancing
balancing with possible
abuse uh uh one point of data we
received when we were working on this
bill uh is that the number of kidney
transfers in New Hampshire is not going
down um but um um one point of that is
that we did not receive with quality
because quantity is very important but
quality uh too because sometimes in this
process uh the same organ are being
offered uh to to different uh let's say
states to different medical
organizations and um uh if let's say
kidney like uh if it's low quality it
would need to be replaced sooner than uh
we would uh like it to be uh so some
opionions of this bill were saying that
uh it will be immoral to deny some
people uh if um but uh that's what
happening uh we we live in a world where
resources are scar including organ
transplants so and there's uh uh the
current legal framework doesn't allow
Market to regulate this scarcity so we
are left to
arbitrary uh
decisions why why it's important like
for example some unhealthy habits let's
say um let's say some State like
indulges more in in drug abuse like uh
can can it be adjusted when deciding who
is a higher priority in the line usually
not but we can have the opposite problem
with some drug
hesitancy uh let's say New Hampshire has
high hesitancy when uh it takes to
people uh
taking what I see an effective drug that
is called Co vaccine and we have some
cases like Daniel coas of New Hampshire
he was on on this organ donation line uh
but he made personal decision not to
take the drug that is called coid
vaccine and decision was made uh to
remove him from organ Nation waiting
list and now he's dead so yeah it's an
important issue of life and death this
bill as was told before me uh maybe it
will conflict with other laws maybe it
not but uh we don't have all the data to
support it uh so uh I'm fine with it
tailing it but I urge you to continue
looking into other ways how can we solve
uh uh organ shortage issues and improve
the situation thank
you thank
you other
discussion see no other discussion okay
I'll ask collector call the
r representative L yes representative
kushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt
yes representative mlan yes yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
pza yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus yes yes representative Canon
yes representative nut
upam representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Sebert yes representative Murray yes
represent McDonald yes 20 to
zero and again there's no objection
we'll put that on the consent
calendar okay the final uh piece of
legislation for us to consider this
morning uh is SB
236 relative to establishing a committee
to study nonprofit organizations
Contracting for the Department of Health
and Human Services for children's
services I'm I will move on to pass for
that that bill uh the subcommittee is
comprised of myself um representative
kushman representative Weber
representative Nutter upam and
representative tez we heard from the
Department of Insurance who was
supportive of it and um again it's a
study committee and um you know
Department of Insurance spel uh spoke at
length about um what they could see as a
very valuable uh aspect to this so for
that reason the committee voted
unanimously subcommittee voted
unanimously to recommend it um for us
for our passage this morning I would
second the
motion yes okay thank you representative
Weber all representative
Weber the only thing I would like to add
is that this is really an incredibly
difficult problem because it deals with
the it the bill sounds like it's very
broad but it really very much deals with
the children who are receiving Services
through um organizations that contract
with
DCF these are our most vulnerable kids
the kids who need the most
services and the problem is that the
organiz ations who arrange for the
services like Waypoint and Easter Seals
and the others um are finding that the
cost of insurance for running the
programs is rapidly getting to the point
where they are going to have to drop the
programs and that would be exceedingly
unfortunate because these are kids that
need help need help here and need help
in the least restrictive environments
that we can find that will appropriately
deal with whatever trauma or issues that
they are dealing with so um getting it
studied and and trying to find an issue
a way of dealing with that particular
issue is particularly important and I
think the
chairman thank you representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chairman I I um
know that there's a lot of resistance to
um creating study committees and I've
been on a at least one study committee
that was incredibly broad um and
impossible to really study in full and
this seems to be an issue that's um
really perfect for a study committee
because it's extremely the task is
extremely narrow and um whether they
solve the issue or not I think it's one
that can be studied in a concise amount
of time and um I'm wrong about this uh
one of the things we suggested as a
subcommittee was that when the report is
written it is written to suggest that of
the uh house members of the study
committee that um one a minimum of one I
I think there are only two from from the
house but I could be wrong about that
but one from Health and Human Services
and one from Commerce because those are
the areas of expertise that are
particularly needed that is correct and
when I did the committee report and sent
it to committee Services I mentioned
that recommendation thank you I specifi
that
recommendation other
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call all representative Lon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth King yes
representative bour yes representative
Nagel yes representative peloso yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay
yes representative fedus
yes representative Canon
yes representative nut
upam representative Shapiro
yes representative
Merchant yes representative Murphy
yes representative Sebert yes
and representative Murray yes and last
but not least representative McDonald
yes 20 to zero okay thank you once again
we will put that on the consent calendar
if that there was no
objection again please myself included
we need to get our committee reports in
and again we uh if we get them in in the
next two or three days that would be
great uh representative Lon would um
next um Monday we've talked about having
our executive session begin at 10: but
um uh the subcommittee for 378 would
like to meet at 10:00 a.m. and then so
that would mean the executive session
would begin at
10:30 uh so I'd like to notice that now
and that'll be reflected in the calendar
also chair yes representative Merchant I
think there's also an amendment I'd like
to have the sub committee for the vision
580 so if we could actually meet at
10:00 amongst us
um before that to go over the amendment
okay so the sub committee for 580 580 at
10 o00 as well all right so the
subcommittee for 580 and 378 they'll
both be meeting at 10:00 a.m. next
Monday and again the executive session
will then begin at
10:30 other yes representative Murray
yeah thank you I only just noticed you
know being new here um it says with um
SB 236 the date is November 1st 2023 did
that get
changed for submitting the report honor
before November 1st
2023 I don't know we could handle that
with a floor Amendment a friendly floor
Amendment or if um if cens this is on
consent perhaps we may want to
reconsider the vote so we can just have
a floor Amendment and put it on to
consent I'm not sure what would be the
fastest approach probably be an even
better idea representative and I
certainly would go along with that okay
so if we could get a floor Amendment for
next week just to change that date
basically push it out a year push it out
a year okay if they want to report
sooner it's not not no harm no foul but
and then to keep our paperwork straight
should um should somebody like myself
move to reconsider now then vote to
reconsider and then recess this until
next week would that be the cleanest way
to move forward to allow this to go on
to consent then I will move to
reconsider the vote on Senate Bill 236
with great thanks to representative
Murray I'll second
it okay any discussion on this motion to
reconsider okay seeing
none keep the clerk busy this morning
sorry you you threw me for a
loop I apologize for not cing earlier
done we greatly appreciate you finding
that now one last thing to do on the
floor in
January represent Leon yes
representative kushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt
yes representative CA
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nel
yes representative pza yes
representative Weber
yes representative McKay yes represent
fedus
yes represent Canon
yes representative nut upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Sebert
yes and representative M Murphy Murray
Murray yes
sorry and represent McDonald yes 20 to
zero
okay representative Shapiro I'm just
wondering who's getting the amendment
I'll I'll do that and representative
McDonald would you put my name on it as
well sure thank
you okay uh any other business to come
before the committee this morning any
housekeeping matters or um any other
subc committies want to meet next Monday
or reprentative L on um after we're done
here i' just like to meet with everybody
who's on the 619 subcommittee to figure
out our best time to meet but we can do
that separate from this
meeting okay anything else this
morning being n thank you all for being
here and I'll see you next Monday we
stand
adjourned